DAN: WELCOME BACK TO
"UNFILTERED."
SINCE 2020 THE POLLING SHOWS THE
LEFT'S GRIP ON:BLACK VOTERS IS
SLIPPING AWAY.
TURNS OUT PEOPLE LOVE FREEDOM
AND LIBERTY AND IT DOESN'T HAVE
A SKIN COLOR.
THAT COULD BE BAD NEWS FOR THE
DEMS COME THE MID-TERMS.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ROBINSON,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TAKING
THE BLACK VOTE FOR IMRANTED FOR
A LONG TIME.
DO YOU THINK WE'LL SEE A MASS
EXODUS FROM THE LEFT TO IT RIGHT
IN THE MID-TERMS?
>> I CERTAINLY DO.
I THINK FOLKS ARE WAKING UP ALL
OVER THIS COUNTRY.
BLACK PEOPLE STARTED TAKING A
LOOK AROUND AND WONDERING WHY
FOR THE LAST 50 YEARS THINGS
HAVE BEEN THE SAME.
WHY THEY ARE SEEING THE SAME OLD
THINGS OH AND OVER AGAIN AND
HEARING THE SAME THINGS OR AND
OVER AGAIN WITH NO POSITIVE
RESULTS.
THEY ARE STARTING TO SEE THEY
NEED TO REAP OUT IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION.
MANY OF THE THINGS THEY HAVE
SEEN IN NORTH CAROLINA AND WHAT
THEY SAW UNPRESIDENT TRUMP
COMPARED TO PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THE ANSWER LIES ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE.
I THINK WE'LL SEE MORE AND MORE
BLACK VOTERS SWITCH OVER TO
REPUBLICAN.
DAN: I THINK SOCIAL MEDIA IS
MAKING IT EASIER TO READ SOME
THOSE CANDIDATES.
HERE IS STACEY ABRAMS'
EXPLANATION ON WHY THEY ARE
LOSING THE BLACK VOTE.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THERE IS A
DISCONNECT BETWEEN YOU AND THIS
IMPORTANT VOTING GROUP.
>> IT'S DESIGNED TO SUPPRESS
TURNOUT.
DAN: SUPPRESS TURNOUT?
I ALWAYS FINE THIS RACIST
SUGGESTING BLACK VOTERS CAN'T
FIGURE OUT HOW TO VOTE.
IT'S NOT COVERTLY RACIST, IT'S
OVERTLY RACIST.
>> THE SOFT BIGOTRY OF LOW
EXPECTATIONS IS NOT SOLVED.
IT'S AS HARD AS A PUNCH.
IT'S DEVASTATING AND HAS BEEN A
STICK OF DYNAMITE IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
TO SUGGEST THOSE WHO SURVIVED
THE MIDDLE PASSAGE, THEN SURVIVE
JIM CROW CAN'T GO DOWN TO THE
DMV TO GET A FREE I.D. IS
INSULTING.
IT'S A FALSE NARRATIVE MYTH, THE
PROPAGATION THAT BLACK FOLKS ARE
VICTIMS AND THEY NEED THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO SUPPLY THEM
WITH EVERYTHING THEY NEED.
WE KNOW IT'S NOT TRUE AND WE
HAVE GOT TO PUSH BACK AGAINST
THAT NARRATIVE.
DAN: NOBODY SAYS IT BETTER THAN
YOU, SIR.
I WILL CONTINUE TO INSIST YOU
ARE A RISING S